oh hi everyone so you're telling me that  i can pick between all these different  kinds of chips yes how do people decide  whoa now what's that beautiful fountain  of rubies would you mind getting me a  copy of the house keys please you don't  need one I'm sorry there are parts of  the house that are unsafe we'll take you  a few days to familiarize yourself then  should you still feel you need them I'll  have copies made one thing 111 the rule  book we call it the Constitution and we  agree to the rules and that's what makes  us Americans it's all that makes us  Americans so don't tell me there's no  rule book and don't not at me like  luckily I'm a botanist  Mars will come to fear my botany power  came out of your way  a giant green matches right now I get us  out of here  two